yeah welcome to this video at some war
zone type of tournament the rapid blitz
this is 30 minutes of three minute games
so bit bit longer than usual the time
control I didn't manage the final again
I mean I didn't manage the proper
starting time I need to get rid of this
and double of course
yeah so I didn't manage the final went
for that at least to have a tournament
of that type i'm dumb i think i'm
actually am the window size is a bit too
too big i hope i'm not too slow with
this a bigger window ok and this guy is
taking ages here hmm
yeah toria tech III is some the normal
booth and I'm setting up a hedgehog type
of position with Bishop e7 white has
some various ways to go okay yeah well
this is some maybe hoping wow these six
I thought maybe hoping for a 95 hoping
for d6 Bishop b5 but f3 is really a
weird move
and yeah well let's get out of this and
play d6 the night it doesn't have a good
square really can go to c4 ok so just
the tech tech deform and of course I
need to play quickly here it's a really
an issue an issue in this some three
minutes some type of tournament to to
win quickly you don't get so many games
in ok blundered deform yeah take this
with check and everything's hanging out
the bishop um yeah let's get stake here
it takes on f6 I'm not sure ok it
doesn't take yeah just just here
yeah I'm attacking the rook so need to
go back Wow ok please don't have much
choice I'll take it if you insist all
right i'll take even that
yeah it takes f.3d I've got 92 no no way
to win the Queen that's a shame
yeah it doesn't really have any threats
at some it's just a safe King now he
doesn't have any attacking pieces so the
main problem so yeah when the Queen come
on if it takes here the 94 wins the
Queen and while he doesn't need to take
can play King somewhere f1 or so or f2
nah yeah this takes ages in the meantime
probably some guy is one two or three
games
yeah it takes on c3 94 wins the Queen
okay so how far the place 14 yeah
someone has got two games played okay
playing chess speed Queens gambit
declined exchange fortunately a rather
dry variation but does I don't have much
choice against this
yeah that's ok now the Queen's on
usually am black goes for Queen to to f6
takes on f6 with the Queen and then
we've got an end game which is slightly
better for white but it's not the kind
of position where you expect to win
quickly and this is exactly what you
need to do in this format win some games
go claim k how to get rid of this bishop
and I need to cover be to problem oh i
blundered the rook in one move while
yanita that could have just taken the
rook gratzi to woo this was lucky okay i
want to get in Bishop f5 exchanged the
bishops that Sam yeah so
very am an ammonia spizz ition this Roxy
to was really complete bogus maybe maybe
I can get some some play and this is
very very ugly for what yeah
yeah probably i need to take
you can just take a three end is much
better
okay so look H for 2g focuses about the
the only idea that I'm that I'm having
here if it takes I'll take young way f6
Knight to f5 would be a very very nice
oh I go them this this looks good nom
Queen g7 what is he going to do so is
there some booths there is some move
yeah I'm very lucky for me I'm just
completely but push it up this opening
title Harold position okay Glock power
96 and he's going for quick glory here
with the scholars mate okay I'm trying
to open up this position quickly am ok
win another tempo oops
yeah the bishop on b7 munches yet
another look let's go for for quick
medium quick Queen f6f to stuff like
that I'm bishops III all right come on
the ship yeah let's let's grab this
it's all wide open we should be too and
playing look at you two
No
yeah the game is still continuing
probably I missed them I cooker win
I
f
yeah now he loses the rest of this stuff
yeah thankfully you didn't drag it on on
the clock some people are doing that
okay so yeah the the French let's play
play that one's French when I 260 some a
strange move we're a force for me not
the way to go
Gavin knight on c6 is it sometimes
playable in the French tuned to go for
for the Sun in this move he probably
wants to castle and give me exchange oh
no he didn't go for that but now I can
spoil has some his castling rights and
let's open up the default quickly get
this a bit of a tragic comical Gandalf
said IBM hard for him to move anything
young Bishop where each III problem just
want to develop quickly now i can i can
drop back his kingdom position is
spoiled already don't need to stay on g6
so i kappa b 2 for a moment a he could
have taken editor it's very risky but
it's a no prob i can i can just you can
just cover be too don't you need to
sacrifice it Wow
should be should see two were dropping
the Queen iya hard for him to to prevent
that Bishop c2 even on g4 I can play
that
92 is also trapping the Queen yeah in
fact on g4 I should go 92 and and to win
it okay so what am i winning the Queen
now take here are 92 92 got Quincy to
okay it doesn't matter i mean this was
my original intention anyway so I'll
take that
maybe here attacking the rook 96
threatened oh ok let's just start with
this
Oh
No
yeah look at the bishop so quite
comfortable
maybe maybe I shouldn't have done that
exchanging Queens it's quicker to to
play for medium ok but ok this is really
very very hopeless to play some some
remove
hmm yeah an awfully long game I
shouldn't def exchange Queens this was
really really stupid
yeah i'm i'm ahead young with the co co
elite some some other people also i've
got four winds not exactly a quick with
all this
yeah let's go I couldn't be fine now I
wanted to go for four stone wall without
the light squared Bishop this is always
an interesting option if you don't have
to bed Bishop then the stone wall is
very often very decent setup okay
and again don't know maybe I can Cass
along with with with the g5 coming
h3 was somewhat strange move weakening
is his sad kingside so well maybe it's
not it's not completely terrible but it
doesn't help
Gavin tinning just just to go g5 opening
up the position
and it's not so clear what is okay this
is this is really cool move after this
is this long thing I mean age 3 was
really weakening g37 ig3 should be
should be on your on your agenda to
check
that don't want to give them a sound
really
get get this this night back into play
and d4 is not exactly a bad square
yeah I'm getting and so it's a matter of
coincidence it's just a random pairing
getting very low rated opposition games
are really one sided there are also some
some stronger players and the in the
field but I didn't I simply didn't get
them
No
yeah queen age for is some mine
excellent yeah even though it should be
five is a bit bit bizarre but um
and yeah Wow kinky one wells King King
II to Queen knife to you don't want to
have okay so let's get this night into
into the attack as well Bishop da daigo
Queen f2 and this really should be
checkmate I mean he's down to a couple
of seconds
okay yeah not really not really able to
to get some put some distance only six
mmhmm yeah just play a friend once with
an extra an extra move have form
I'm shipped to us promised you could
move why not busy beach Bishop e2 in
syrup should be three oz better
especially with a form okay it's not not
the move I like to play oh no no it's um
no it's playing playing good moves all
of a sudden I night a 5 mm yeah okay not
not enthusiastic about this so try to
get rid of the Queen's yeah but he
really wants to avoid it mmm yeah well I
but I must insist I can I cannot play
this with Queens on the board with the
King on everyone
of course on this is just fine for black
so just a question how fine is he much
better slightly better not quite sure
really played that this was very bad
opening play he just lost the temple
with these 66 and so on but I just
played it so badly that it all worked
out fine they even was so slow slow
while doing it now this now I'm
improving a bit this looks looks nice
again not like spectacular but decent ok
he's got the f6 coming where'd you go
him quickly I need to play quickly
stabilize so let's exchange him wow not
exchanging their surprising
yeah I have just had a look at the clock
time and I need to need to be quick here
whoops wanted to grab III really this
what I wasn't intended
yeah it's not exactly great
he cannot do much really but I'm on 20
27 seconds
No
only plan is to second g6 and he can
easily prevent it but it doesn't amazing
oh I didn't expect that
okay yeah this was very bad we played
played a bad game there ok so now i
think it is I've got at best this game
they can try to try to win and dupes and
while this is just just a pawn
with with no compensation at all
yeah maybe you can get it back with rook
do you want out something but it's it's
not great okay yeah it's I don't I won't
manage I think there's just about one
minute left in the tournament and how to
win this in one minute don't don't see
how
I mean it's um it's not even so clear
how to get anything substantial in the
first place ok let's it's better for
black but in one minute and no way to to
get to win
can I g54 some probably coming it's not
scary or anything but I think the time
is close too close to run out for the
tournament we're expecting yeah just
three seconds left so that's it probably
a month or next second place or
something yeah second place okay let's
let's check the final standing yeah this
is good someone managed here v.v GQ we
managed to win seven games and I just 16
games if you look at the average
opposition had a very low average
opposition with 1600 and I simply didn't
win cook a cook cook enough quickly
enough and yeah it's a it's it's those
you can only win if you really managed
to win some quickly with with mates
preferably so that it's not dragged on
but on a good day you can manage 10
games in this kind of tournament but I
only managed 6 I want all of them but it
was only good for second place yeah I
hope you enjoyed it the opposition
wasn't wasn't too great but um it's
nothing I can I can influence in this
format thanks for watching